How you doing? I'm pretty good. How are
you?
Fine, thank you. Good, good, good.
You're a Muslim?
Yeah, I'm a Muslim. All right, welcome
to the panel.
So, we're just we're just asking why do
you
why do Muslims dislike Paul?
Yeah. I have some little questions to
ask.
Well, at first you got to answer why do
you dislike Paul first?
Why must Who is Paul?
Paul is an apostle of Jesus Christ, the
Lord.
But
Paul what? What is his whole name?
It's only Paul Paul what? Paul of
Tarsus.
Paul?
Yes, Paul of Tarsus.
Paul of Tarsus.
Okay.
Do you know about Paul?
No. Not really?
Oh, well, he uh Yeah. He started off as
a persecutor of the believers in Jesus.
But then Jesus visited him
while he was on his way to uh persecute
more Christians.
And after Jesus visited him, Paul
converted and started preaching the
gospel and and became a Christian.
Okay.
What do you think about that?
Um is is there any proof is is there any
proof where Paul becoming Christian in
the Bible? What chapter uh what chapter
of verse? Yes, Acts chapter 9.
Acts chapter 9, that's where Paul has
his uh
conversion.
Okay.
I have some little questions. I don't
know much about Paul, but I have some
little questions. Maybe if you can clear
this stuff, maybe I understand.
I have a you have a lot lot of
background, isn't I can I can hear your
dog barking in your background, bro.
Yeah, yeah. I'm
Can you get to somewhere quieter? I just
moved it from there.
Yeah, I'm moving. I'm moving a little
bit All right. As I'm I'm going to mute
you. You can unmute when you're ready,
okay?
Got the dogs around there. Got the
crickets around there.
You said it's evening time, so that's
cool.
Uh but yeah, guys, make sure you guys
hit the like button.
Make sure you guys hit the like button
and
um show some love, man. Also, when the
live is over, I want you guys and for
the people who are watching this after
the live stream, tell me um what do you
guys think about the previous guest. Um
maybe your favorite moments in that
conversation.
And also what you think about this guest
now that I'm talking to
as he uh comes and he gets ready to
unmute as he's getting to a quieter
place.
I want to hear you guys' thoughts. I
like seeing your opinions on the
conversation.
Um if there's maybe something that maybe
you would have said, how would you have
approached um certain questions and what
was said. I'd like to hear from you guys
in the comment section.
All right. All right. All right.
Come on, Ishmael, man. You're holding up
my live stream, man.
You got to You got to unmute.
Are you in a quieter place now?
You got to unmute your mic, Ishmael.
All right.
Just come up when you're ready again.
We'll see what we got.
Oh lord.
What's up, fam? What's up, man? You know
this is a rare one.
What you mean? It's rare that you make
it up on the stage.
Nah, I've been chilling, bro.
But, um Okay.
This man says it's rare. The live look
dry right now. What's going on? Oh, it's
more on YouTube, man. I got 2,000 people
watching on YouTube.
Oh, okay. That's where you be doing most
of your stuff now? Yeah. Well, that's
that's always where I've been doing most
of my stuff. TikTok is like just for
fun.
Oh, for real? I thought you was on
TikTok first. Heck, no. No.
I was I was on the
you met Uthman, you you was on YouTube?
Yeah. I I didn't I didn't have a TikTok
at the time.
I I I've been on TikTok only for like
maybe a few months over a year now.
Mhm. Yeah. I've been on TikTok for the
last three.
Cuz I remember I seen that Uthman video,
and I remember the first time I seen you
on TikTok. I was like, "Wait, hold on.
Aren't you that dude that that was
talking to Uthman?" Yeah. That was
funny. Yeah. Yeah. Like a year ago.
Oh, yeah. Facts. Facts. Nah, this is so
dumb. But, uh anyways, though, um
What's the argument for today? Why do
Muslims dislike Paul? Why do Muslims
dislike Paul?
Oh, you finally switched it up, man.
That's what's up.
I try to be versatile, man, you know.
Try to throw on a little
little new ones.
I'm proud of you, man. You trying to
come with more arguments. But, uh
I'd be even more proud if you say your
shahada, but uh yeah. Why do we dislike
Paul? You know what? I'll I'll say my
I'll say my shahada if you can give good
and consistent reasons why you dislike
Paul as long as they don't backfire.
Oh, yeah. Facts. Um
Well, number one, uh kind of like the
last guy was saying, who is Paul? Like,
how do we even know
We don't really know much about Paul. We
We actually don't know nothing about
Paul outside of the Bible.
Um
Not at all. Like, no sort Like, who's
his parents?
What does that matter?
tell me his mother or his father's name?
No, what does that matter?
Cuz
I mean,
whenever whenever somebody when they
Like, for example, if I said
If I said God Logic said this, Mhm. and
it's just a claim.
You'll be like, "How you know How you
know God Logic said that?"
How and and how does How does knowing
the name of my mom and dad verify or
validate or invalidate whether or not I
said what I said or what the claim says
I said?
So, it's about supporting your evidence.
Like, for example, you could be like,
No, I know, Lee. That's what I'm asking.
How does
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, how does How does knowing the name
of my dad or mom help that?
Yeah. Uh so, kind of goes with Hadith
science, which I know you don't agree to
those standards cuz of the Bible, but uh
yeah, so I mean, it's very crucial like
whenever you're explaining something to
have details and to have
knowledge surrounding the topic because
if you just kind of make a claim like
you could say,
"Oh,
You could say anything. My My question
is, how does knowing my mom and dad's
name
verify what I said or didn't say?
So, it's to verify that that person
that's taking this information
actually knows this person and is a
first-hand witness account.
What does that
That still does not tell me anything.
Knowing the name of my mother and father
does not
validate or invalidate what I say today.
Like, if you ask somebody,
um if they said, "Oh, yeah, Avery said
this." And you say, "Oh, okay. Well,
uh wait, who who is Avery actually?
Like, do you What's his mom and dad's
name?" And they don't know. Does that
invalidate that I said what they said I
said?
No. No, no. No, no. But no, but the real
No, but realistically it would be it
would be more so
so-and-so said this about so-and-so was
witness GodLogic saying this. Then it
would be like, "Okay, how do you know
GodLogic?"
Yeah.
Did you watch him on Tik Tok? Did you
meet him in person?
Yeah, can somebody know me without
knowing my mom and dad?
Yeah, well, that was just an example I
gave as mom and dad, but
But it's the first thing you brought up
about Paul. It's just
Yeah, yeah. No, so it's it's more than
just that. Okay. So, let let's So, let's
throw that out there. Let's throw
knowledge of parents is out the window
from now on. And I hope that the rest of
the Muslims hear this.
This is a silly thing to bring up when
it comes to knowing if somebody said
something or not.
So, what is the real problem that you
have with Paul?
Well,
of course one
that, but number two, um,
I don't agree that
we threw that out.
You threw it out. I still I still take
that as substantial. I I feel like
that's something substantial for you to
make claims. Uh, you have to show me
that. You have to show me that that's
substantial. Show me that it's
substantial.
that. I'll I'll concede to that.
Okay, so it's out the window. So,
it's out the window for now? So, it's
out the window for now? So, it's out the
window for now? So, it's out the window
for now? So, it's out the window for
now? So, it's out the window for now?
So, it's out the window for now? So,
it's out the window for now? So, it's
out the window for now?
I concede to that for now. All right, so
it's out the window. All right, go
ahead. What's What's So, what's What's
number one then? Give me Give me
something.
Yeah, so number one,
uh,
I don't believe Paul ever met Jesus.
Okay.
Let's go with that.
you ain't even got to continue. Yep.
Paul didn't meet Jesus. So, Paul not
meeting Jesus, does that um, make him
unreliable?
It doesn't.
It doesn't make him unreliable as a
person, but if he speaks on Jesus
and he never met Jesus, then that makes
him unreliable.
Got it. So, it doesn't mean that he's
unreliable personally, but if he speaks
on Jesus, right, says that Jesus said
things or taught certain things or
whatever, but never met him himself,
then that would mean he's unreliable
pertaining to the to Jesus.
Got you.
Correct. All right. So, let's just go
with that.
Did Muhammad meet Jesus?
Yes.
Muhammad met Jesus.
Mhm.
You want me to tell you when?
When when did Muhammad meet Jesus on the
night journey?
You got it. I didn't have to tell you.
I'm proud of you.
Alhamdulillah.
You've been doing your studying. Good
job.
Good job. He met all the prophets.
You want me to give you an example?
Watch this.
No, it's all it's all good. It's all
good. You got it. He met him in the
night journey.
Did Jesus
Did Jesus meet Moses?
it's it's all good. Yes, actually. But
it's
Okay, thank you. No, but Jesus actually
met Moses while he was here on earth.
But you also claim that Okay, you claim
that as being believing that he's the
God of the Old Testament. Sure, okay,
that's cool.
In the New Testament.
Yes, but also in the New Testament In
the New Testament.
Yes, in the New Testament, Moses and
what was it? Aaron appeared to him and
Elijah.
Or yeah, yeah, yeah. I You you get it.
So so they So he So he appeared. So So
he So he met Jesus. But Yeah, but but
but Moses was but Moses was not alive at
that time.
No, God is the God of the living, not
the dead. Abraham, all of them, they're
alive with God.
Just Just like how you Just like how the
Quran says that the martyrs are alive
with Allah. They're not dead. Yes. Yes,
they're alive in another They're alive
in another realm, but as of a earthly
realm, Jesus was on Earth when he This
Jesus was on Earth when he said that
they appeared. So,
Did they come down from heaven and
appear on Earth? Yeah, yeah.
So, the angels could I mean so the
prophets could come down from heaven?
Yeah, by the power of Yeah, by the power
of God, yeah.
Is
Wait. Wait. Time out. Time out. Time
out. Time out.
So, so any of the prophets at any time
can appear on Earth? Yeah, if God wants
them to. Yeah.
What What What would be the need of
that?
There is no need for him to do anything.
He could do that if he wants to, right?
But why would he Why would he want his
prophet
For Because Because I'll I'll I'll tell
you why. Because I'm showing you that
job.
showing you that you have the disciples
that are there witnessing Jesus.
So, this is their first time witnessing
the glory of Jesus. And they're even
witnessing Muhammad and Elijah coming to
him, submitting to him. And then the
voice from heaven, the father, who
declares that that's his son who they
should listen to.
So, all of this is for the benefit not
of Jesus or anybody else. It's for the
disciples that are there.
To show that, you know, okay, yeah, this
this is the one.
Okay.
Okay. Got you. Okay. Understood. So,
Wait, I have a question. What's your So
So wait wait. So, what's your opposition
to the night journey then? If you If you
accept that, what is your opposition?
Well, I don't accept it, but let's just
go with it.
No, no, I'm saying if you accept that
Elijah and uh Moses appeared If you
accept that,
Mhm. what why do you oppose the prophet
going to heaven and talking to them? But
you But you don't oppose the prophet
meeting on Earth.
listening to me, bro. I don't. I'm not
I'm not I'm not opposing you. I'm
actually going with you.
So, if you're saying that that Muhammad
met Jesus on the night journey, which,
you know, as theists and spiritually,
you know, miraculously, maybe that could
happen. We should have no problem with
that type of stuff.
So, then I would say, then you shouldn't
oppose Paul meeting Jesus when he was on
his way to Damascus.
This is where I This is where I oppose
that. Why? Number one,
number one,
Issa even Miriam
I don't know who that is, but okay.
Okay.
I don't know who Jesus is because it was
Cuz it's Cuz it's it's Iesous in the 19
in the 1611 and then I don't know who he
is.
Yeshua and
uh uh
I'm not going to go through all that.
But anyways, I'm not I'm not about to go
through all that. But anyways, you you
get the idea. But anyways, a prophet
leaving this planet, God ascended him,
and we understand that
he's not to come back until he is needed
to come back again. Um we don't Or until
Come on, man.
He's not to come back until the day of
judgment. So, when he ascended
Wait, lean, please. You explaining
the night journey and your
interpretation of that is irrelevant
here. You believe that in some
miraculous realm, some spiritual thing
took place to where that allowed
Muhammad to meet the rest of the
prophets.
Fine. You don't even have to interpret
the deepness of that. You can have it.
Okay. So, just deal with
If you accept that, why do you oppose
Paul meeting Jesus on the on his way to
Damascus.
Got you. Got you. Okay, so we both
accept something miraculous could
happen. All right. So, the way that you
the way the reason I oppose that is
because the way that you would
understand if this person's being
truthful or not is because from the
sustenance of what they're speaking. SO,
PAUL
SO, YOU DON'T you don't deny that Jesus
that Paul could have met really met
Jesus on the road to Damascus.
You only go against him meeting Jesus
because you don't believe what Paul
taught.
Well, Paul he number well, according to
the Bible,
which of course I don't accept it as an
authority, but according to the Bible it
says things that like for example, Jesus
he spoke in parables. Paul never
mentioned that. Uh Wait. Wait. That's
not that's not a denial of Jesus
speaking in parables. Layman, come on,
man.
I but I but what I'm saying what I'm
saying is Paul Wait. Wait. Wait.
Before you continue. Before you
continue. Look. Before you continue.
Before you continue. Look.
Layman.
So, now it sounds like so at first the
issue was Paul didn't meet Jesus.
And now we see that that's not really an
issue. The issue is now switching to
well, it's what Paul taught.
It's what Paul taught. Okay.
So, Paul
says that he met Jesus,
right? But doesn't mention that Jesus
taught in parables. So, that makes him
unreliable. Is that correct?
So, you kind of misrepresented my point.
I'm not saying that
I'm not I'm not granting that he met
Jesus. I'm saying that what he taught
makes me believe that he never met
Jesus.
So, we have this claim from both sides.
Muhammad claims that he met Jesus. Paul
claims that he met Jesus. Okay? And so
you're showing me why you believe one
but not the other.
So we have the claim from Paul.
However,
you don't believe Paul actually met
Jesus because
boom.
Because he doesn't mention if he if he
met Jesus, he would have mentioned that
when Jesus was here, he taught in
parables, but Paul never said anything
about that. Is that correct?
Yep. Okay.
Muhammad also says that he met Jesus.
Jesus spoke in parables.
Does Muhammad mention that Jesus spoke
in parables?
Muhammad didn't he he or the well
I'm not going to speak on everything
that he said about that cuz I don't know
everything surrounding that. But
but what I do know is like I don't know
about him having a full conversation
with Jesus in that night journey.
But I'm not going to speak on that cuz I
don't have knowledge on that.
But
but
what I speak on is what Allah has taught
us about Jesus or well what I believe
Allah taught us about Jesus. Well well
I'm confused here. Okay. I'm confused
here.
Paul didn't mention
how Jesus taught in parables yet he met
him.
Muhammad also I guess the answer is no,
right? Muhammad didn't mention that
Jesus taught in parables. Is that
correct?
I don't have knowledge on that. I do not
have knowledge on that.
what So I'm not going to give you a From
from what you know, you don't know of
any mention of Muhammad saying that
Jesus taught in parables, right?
I haven't read all the Hadith on it. So
I don't I don't know everything. I know
that's I'm just asking I'm just asking
I'm just asking based on what you do
know. Based on what you do know, there
is no mention of Muhammad saying that
Jesus taught in parables from what you
know so far, right?
Sure. Yeah, I I haven't read anything
about that yet.
worries. So,
you have
Muhammad
who doesn't say that Jesus taught in
parables.
You have Paul Paul who doesn't mention
how Jesus taught in parables. You said
that this makes Paul's
claim of his experience meeting Jesus
false.
So then likewise, it would make
Muhammad's claim of meeting Jesus false,
right? If we're consistent.
So I wouldn't say that necessarily. Mhm.
necessarily because number one Mhm. Like
I said, I do not know all the
circumstances surrounding the meeting of
Jesus. I just know that he did meet
Jesus along the way. I do not know
everything surrounding it, but
everything that I learned from Jesus, I
don't get from the prophet. I get it
from the Quran and what God what I
believe God is speaking directly with
him. So Jesus
So when God says that he is a Muslim
Mhm.
God knows everything, so that's what I
understand. I know Paul doesn't know
everything. I got you. I got you. I got
you.
Paul could have been hallucinating. God
So and and and
and Muhammad could have been
hallucinating too, right?
No.
So you and and I like the chuckle there.
I like
I like the chuckle
because Liam, I think you're smart
enough to see your double standards. See
all all Notice how Liam, I haven't even
like
refuted anything you said about
Muhammad, right? I haven't I haven't
said anything. I haven't gone against it
in any way. All I've done was just apply
your own logic back to Muhammad to see
if you would be consistent. And every
time I do
you flip-flop and you show your double
Can you at least be honest with me and
say and and and acknowledge that you do
see the double standard that you're
applying here?
No, I do understand where you're coming
from. I understand the angle that you're
coming from and you're saying, "Okay, if
you believe this, why don't you believe
that?" I understand the angle that
you're coming from. Mhm. Uh but it's
more to it than just those things. It's
all of these things all combined.
But we see Okay, good. But here it is.
We see all of these things combined
together, these accusations and these
problems that you have with Paul, all of
these things combined together can be
also applied to Muhammad.
But you're not willing to apply them to
Muhammad. You're only willing to apply
them to Paul.
Do you see And and that's where the
inconsistency
and the double standard is being
exposed. That's what I'm doing.
I'm saying that if you're going to say
Paul is unreliable and false for all of
these reasons combined, then you have to
say Muhammad is false for all of those
same reasons combined.
Not necessarily, and I'm not really
trying to speak on the prophet. I'm just
trying to speak on what I understand of
Paul. I'm not really trying to speak on
Islam itself, but This is This is the
whole point. Look, I just I showed you
my hand.
My whole hand and my cards, the reason
for this topic is to expose Muhammad and
expose y'all's beliefs in Muhammad.
I'm showing you that your accusations
against Paul
actually work against Muhammad.
So if you're going to say that Paul is a
false messenger, a false prophet, a
false teacher, unreliable for the
reasons that you give, then you have to
say Muhammad is false and unreliable for
those same reasons. That's my point.
Well, it also go is is also is more to
that. Like, for example, Paul's
character. He openly admits to being a
liar. He openly admits to having a thorn
of Satan being in his flesh. He openly
admits to robbing the churches blind. So
he openly admits to being a Jew to those
who are Jews for them to
One at a time, Lee.
One at a time. You're cooking right now.
So now it has switched over.
We see the accusation against Paul's
claim of having a spiritual experience
compared to Muhammad's claim of having
an experience a spiritual experience
and the reasons why Lee here
doesn't believe Paul but believes
Muhammad those are same reasons
are the same reasons why he can't
believe Muhammad actually met Jesus and
had a spiritual experience.
But in short
But I'm not trying to bring the prophet
into it. No, I'm not trying to bring the
prophet into it. No, I'm not trying to
bring the prophet into it. No, I'm not
trying to bring
no choice.
What I know what I know what I know of
Jesus comes from the Quran. Really? What
language did Jesus speak?
What language did Jesus
What are you trying to What are you
trying to get at? What
language
did Jesus speak?
Honestly, where you about to try to lead
that to? That's not relevant. Woah.
That's like me asking you Time out.
That's like me asking you what language
did Adam speak?
One second.
One second. I'll be right back. I'll be
right back.
Sorry, I had to get my utensils.
What language did he speak?
Bro, you making all that noise, man. I'm
just trying to cuz I'm stirring. I'm
stirring it. I'm cooking it.
I just got to
Anyway. What What language did he speak?
That is not relevant. It doesn't matter.
And that does not matter to a person
like me.
Can I tell you why it matters?
Because you just said
You just said
that everything you know about Jesus and
everything you learned from Jesus
comes from the Quran.
Okay. Let's see if that actually holds.
What language did Jesus speak, Lean?
You claim that he spoke Greek. You claim
that he spoke Hebrew. I don't know
Aramaic.
I didn't
No, I've heard you I've heard you make
that claim.
to jump out the pot. Stay in there.
What But for example
language, Lean?
Stop trying to jump out the pot.
What language did Jesus speak?
I understand where you're going to go.
You're going to say, "Oh, the Quran
doesn't tell you that." Okay. I didn't
say that.
But What language did Jesus speak?
The language that the Hebrews or that
the Hebrews spoke at that time, Aramaic.
Aramaic. Or that the Jews spoke at that
time, Aramaic. Is that in your Quran?
Come on, bro.
Is that in your Quran? I just told you
your argument before you said it. Very
good.
Is it in Quran?
No, the people around him spoke that
language. Wow. So, where do you get it
from, actually, Lane?
Where do you get it from that Jesus
spoke Aramaic
and lived with people who spoke Hebrew
and Aramaic? Where do you get that from?
There are sources that go that are
around that time. There's many of
sources. Don't just say the Bible. I I
didn't say anything. But but I
So, what sources tell you that Jesus
spoke Aramaic?
The Jews of that time spoke Aramaic.
What source do you have that says Jesus
spoke Aramaic? Remember, the Jews were
everywhere. They're all over the place.
They were in Arabia, they were
in Egypt, they were all over the place.
What tells you that?
I don't think I don't think that matters
though. Like regardless, let's say he
spoke Chinese. I don't think it matters.
Oh, it does matter. I don't think it
matters.
Oh, it matters. Why does it matter?
Because what matters is is you just said
that everything you know about Jesus
comes from the Quran.
But yet you just gave me some
information about Jesus that doesn't
come from the Quran. Yet you stated it
as fact. So, wherever you're getting
this from, you're relying on it as your
historical fact on the life of Jesus, at
least in this aspect.
So, what source is that, Lane?
That tells you that Jesus spoke Aramaic.
Bro, you're going to say the only two
There's only two phrases in the Bible
that he ever uses that were
Aramaic.
Eli Eli lama sabachthani and abba.
That's the only two things that you'll
say. So, are you saying
just but the way I can say ola, I can
say como estas, I can say
I can eat food, I can say different
things, but does that mean I speak
Spanish?
so just Here's the question.
That's why I feel like it's not it's not
relevant though. Regardless of the
matter of what he said.
So, what what source tells you
that he spoke Aramaic?
You're close.
You're You're so hot, man. You're You're
right there.
You're saying it like only one thing
says it.
I'm only asking you what's the source.
What is it? Just say it. So, we can move
on.
Bro, I just said there's only two
phrases. It doesn't say Jesus spoke
Aramaic. It said he said in this in this
language. Eli Eli lama sabachthani.
Okay, sure. So, the Bible demonstrates
that Jesus spoke
Aramaic.
So, is the source the Bible?
It It makes a claim that he said
something, but Is the So, is the source
the Bible?
But I don't believe that he said that. I
don't believe he said my God my God, why
have you forsaken me?
no Hey, I don't even believe he said
that. So, that's not my source.
out the pot. Stop it.
He never got crucified, so I don't even
accept that.
worries, habibi. Stop Hey, stop trying
to jump out the pot.
So, if you don't accept
that as your source for Jesus speaking
Aramaic,
what is your source?
It's not relevant. It's It's not
relevant.
relevant, ladies and gentlemen.
It's not relevant when my man here,
Lane, says that everything that I know
about Jesus
comes from the Quran. And as soon as I
ask him one question about Jesus
that he doesn't get from the Quran, ALL
OF IT FALLS. NOW, ALL OF A SUDDEN, it's
irrelevant.
Do you see
I'm not saying Okay, I'm not saying that
I know 100% for sure
what language he spoke. Really? Cuz
Allah Cuz Allah didn't tell us that in
the Quran.
Then why in the world did you say
Aramaic and Hebrew?
I said that that was claims that were
made about him.
That's not what you said. You said he
spoke
that that was claims.
wait. You didn't say that. When I asked
you, you said he spoke the language of
his people at the time, which was Hebrew
and Aramaic. Those are your exact words.
If you want to rewatch this, it's on
YouTube. You can rewind it.
You said that exactly.
So, you didn't say, "Oh, this is what
people say he might have spoke."
my educated guess. Okay, that would be
my educated guess. I don't know for
sure.
educated You have an educated guess that
Jesus spoke Aramaic and Hebrew.
Based on what source is this education
coming from?
The language that
they that the Hebrews wrote at that
time. What do you mean?
How do you know that Jesus was living in
a time where he would have been speaking
Aramaic and Hebrew? And how do you know
that Jesus himself spoke the language?
Cuz just cuz he lives around people who
speak it, doesn't mean that he's
speaking it himself. What is your
evidence, your source, that he spoke it
himself.
Just because somebody makes a claim
that that doesn't that doesn't validate
the Bible though is what I'm trying it
doesn't validate it. Hey.
Stay in the pot.
If I made a book and I said if I made a
book and I said God logic spoke in the
language of his people at that time.
Hey. Stay in the pot.
What's your source for your educated
guess?
Bro, you doing too much with that, bro.
Did you wait?
What's your source?
Bro, I just made an educated guess.
Okay. I'm not saying bro, I'm not saying
I know 100% sure. I do not know. So so
do you
I got you. So do you see how
um
Let me let me let me just ask you this.
Just forget that then. Let me ask you
this.
Um
Where did Jesus preach?
To the people of Bani Israel. I said
where?
Not to who, where?
You're you're trying to ask me all
biblical questions. No, I'm just asking
you basic questions on Jesus. Like the
language he spoke, I think that that's a
basic question. Where he preached, I
think that's a basic question. Where did
he preach? Cuz your Quran says that he
preached to the gospel. Your Quran says
that. Where did he do that?
I don't know and it's not relevant. I I
don't know 100%. You know all right,
what's the what's your educated guess?
According if if if I'm using I I don't I
don't know.
Do you have an educated guess?
Nope.
So, you had an educated guess on the
language he spoke, but you don't have an
educated guess on where he preached?
The people of Bani Israel
They were What do you mean? They was in
that area. Okay, sure.
What area? That's what that's that was
the claim. That's that That's That's
something that was been claimed. Okay,
that's something that's been claimed.
What area were they in?
Bro, okay, according to your book it
says they were in one area.
whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa,
whoa, WHOA, WHOA, WHOA, WHOA, WHOA,
WHOA, DON'T
MY BOOK IS UNRELIABLE, REMEMBER?
What area were they in?
Around.
It's not relevant. It's not relevant.
it takes
The question is the What's relevant is
what What is he preaching? It's not
relevant.
Wherever he's at, what was he teaching?
All right, I'll give you another one.
You know what? Forget it. Forget what he
spoke.
Forget where he preached.
Who are his disciples?
What do you mean? They were Muslims. Who
were they?
Matter of fact, you don't even got to
tell me all of them. Give me one name.
Bro, anyways.
You said you know everything about Jesus
from the Quran. Give me one name of his
disciple.
Bro, all of the import The all of the
important information of Jesus
is through the Quran.
Okay.
All of the IMPORTANT
YOU KNOW WHAT? OKAY, YOU
YOU GOT ME. YOU GOT me there.
All of the important information about
Jesus is in the Quran.
How did he pray? Yes. How did he pray?
He prays like a Muslim. That's simple.
Show me.
He said I He said I indeed am a Muslim.
Show me how he prayed.
However Allah willed him to do. Allah
willed him. Allah I don't know. Allah
knows best.
Wait, you don't think it's important to
know how your Messiah prayed?
what I do not know. I do not I do not
know.
you don't you think it's important to
know how your Messiah prayed?
And how he probably taught how to pray?
You don't think that's important?
When he comes back, he will pray like
like a Muslim.
When he comes back, he will pray like a
Muslim. But when he was here on Earth,
how did he pray?
I can only assume that he prayed like a
Muslim.
You can only assume that he prayed like
a Muslim. So, no answer to that, huh? No
answer to that important question.
It's not relevant. It's not relevant.
Okay. How do Okay.
It's not It's not relevant.
Wait, wait, wait. How did Adam pray?
It's not relevant how Jesus the Messiah
prayed and taught how to pray.
But
just a few seconds ago
you said that you know everything about
Jesus
and you know it from the Quran.
So, do you see how really with basic
questions
you don't know nothing about Jesus. You
don't know what he preached, where he
preached, how he preached, to who he
preached to specifically, you don't know
who his disciples were,
if he chose his disciples, how he chose
them, who they were, what did they
preach. You don't know none of that, yet
he trusted them to do it? You don't know
none of that. You don't know how he
prayed, how he talked to pray.
Wait, you know what? Here's another
question.
Did Jesus fast? Wait. Wait, time out. I
can ask you this about literally any
prophet in the Bible.
fast?
He was a Muslim. He did exactly exactly
what God wanted him to do.
Did he fast?
Bro, you're asking me for a biography on
his whole life. But you said you know
everything about You said you know
everything about Jesus and you know it
from the Quran. I didn't say I know
everything about Jesus.
you know
You did. You said you everything you
know about Jesus.
I've never made that claim, not once.
let me not misrepresent you. You said
that you know
you know about Jesus. And the
information you know about Jesus is from
the Quran.
And then, when we tested that, you said,
"Well, the important things I know about
Jesus are from the Quran."
But the important things like how he
prayed,
you don't know that. What about his
fasting? Did he fast?
That's what you subjectively believe is
more important than another thing. Allah
revealed what's what's important TO THE
PEOPLE.
OH, SO NOW what's important is
subjective. So, when we bring up things,
you can subjectively decide whether what
I bring up is important or not so that
you can use that as your scapegoat. Do
you see what's happening here?
Okay, now let now You just what You just
put me through a whole questioning.
Okay.
Tell me what language did Adam speak?
This was the very first person
that was created in your Bible. Okay. To
prove a point.
What What language did Adam speak?
say. The Bible doesn't say.
You see, I I I did this I did this to
prove to you a point.
That every Now, notice let me show you
the reverse with me and Adam.
Everything that I know about Adam comes
from the Bible. Whatever's is mentioned
about Adam in the Bible, I don't know
nothing about.
You see how I did that?
I rely on the Bible.
You claim to not rely on the Bible, but
you think you know things about Jesus.
You get what I'm saying? But yet the
things that you say that you know about
Jesus comes from the Bible, like him
speaking Aramaic for example. Or him
living in a time and a place where
people spoke Hebrew and Aramaic. That
all comes from the Bible, not your
Quran, not your Hadith. So, do you see
the difference here? I'm being
consistent with my position while you're
not.
Okay, and I'm consistent with that view.
Like I said, I don't know.
I can only make an educated guess on
what
You can't. You can't make
You can't
any educated consensus. Consensus on by
who who's the consensus?
Within Tafsir
Within Tafsir Whenever they're certain
Within Tafsir they will speak on things
and or they'll give they'll expand on
different things.
They just they disagreed on on on Jesus
a lot. On the language he spoke or
whatever, they disagreed. They had
different opinions.
But here's the thing. So so they have
different opinions is not something that
Where would they have gotten it from?
Where would they have gotten it from
that he would have spoken Hebrew or
Aramaic? Some of them deny that he spoke
Aramaic and only spoke Hebrew. Um but
where would they get this information
from? That he spoke Hebrew or Aramaic.
Where did they get that from?
They would get it from the Jews.
They would get it from the Jews?
Where did the Jews get it from?
What do you mean? Where would the Jews
be getting it from what language Jesus
spoke?
They had their own they have their own
commentaries.
And where Where commentaries get it
from?
What's their source?
I don't know.
See,
all of this
just to avoid acknowledging that the
source
is the Bible.
All of that all all of that just to
avoid saying, "All right, Logic.
All right, Avery.
It's enough. I give up. You're right.
You know, even though I didn't
So you're saying the
Wait, so you're saying the Muslims
Bible.
Wait, so you're saying the Muslims that
wrote Tafsir, you're saying their source
was the Bible? Oh, yeah. A lot A lot of
their sources come from the Bible. Their
information about Jesus, the Jews, the
previous prophets, a lot they they take
from the Bible a lot
actually. Okay. I'll actually You know
what? I'll I'll do a fun session. I'll
do an entire YouTube uh might do a live
stream. I'll make it a live stream so we
can go deep into it. And uh I'll show
you the top seer that are pulling from
the Bible for their commentary in Islam.
I'll show you that.
It's actually interesting subject.
So look, this is how we got here.
We got here because
we were comparing Muhammad and Paul.
And we were seeing the double standard
from our friend Liam here
of his accusations against Paul,
but if they're turned on Muhammad,
then Muhammad's also a an unreliable
false prophet.
You see how this goes, man?
So if you're going to say that Paul is
false and unreliable, you have to say
the same thing about Muhammad.
Okay?
I'm a Paul Wait. Okay. But Paul claimed
to be a liar. Paul claimed to be a liar.
Yes. Paul claimed to be a liar. So
whoever lies is a false messenger, is
that right?
He claimed himself that he was a liar.
So whoever lies is a false messenger, is
that right?
He claimed that that was his character.
So, whoever
is your character
So, whoever lies is a false messenger,
is that correct?
Go ahead, say yes. I'm not saying Wait.
I'm not saying that a person
If Paul is a liar, is he a false He can
lie. Anyway, anybody can lie.
We're all humans. What I'm saying, being
a liar Uh-huh.
and that being your character and that
not the same thing as someone falling.
What do you call someone who has lied?
What do you mean? What do you call
someone who tells lies?
Depends on the It depends on the case.
Uh Emem, this is where I got
There's no such thing There's no such
There's
here, man. I'm going to move on from
here.
I do appreciate you coming up, man. It
was fun. I'm going to let the next guest
come up, okay?
Okay, but there's no such thing as a
white lie and you telling lies
like bold-faced lies. That's This is a
difference. Got you. I got you.
Well, you have a good day, man. Thanks
for coming.
All right, bro. All right.
Woo!
Man.
What do you do with that, huh?
That was fun. I'm not going to lie.
Emem made that fun. He was a good sport
about everything. He made that fun.